[Musik]
haare
die idylle auf diesen thurgauer weigern
könnte einen einladen über die
beschaulichen seiten des lebens auf dem
lande zu berichten über den biobauern
markus ramseier zb der gerne neues
ausprobiert und von der milchwirtschaft
und vom ackerbau lebt
[Musik]
doch dieser film erzählt wie dieser
bauer zusammen mit seiner frau für seine
überzeugungen einstehen und wie es ihm
dabei ergeht
begonnen hat alles vor drei jahren als
das bauernehepaar einen eritreischen
flüchtling zu sich holte
da
[Musik]
das ist ein baum ein schweizer warm
der bund und der bauernverband hatten
ein integrationsprojekt klaus jetz und
dafür gesucht gefahr leitet sie immer
wieder feuer und denen ich denke das ist
da wäre typisch für mich wenig weiße
kongo mit solid und die ganz
flüchtlingsheimen natürlich irgendwelche
belastet die internetgemeinde genommen
und stellen dominante und ist doch
schade wenn wir nicht jetzt eine arbeit
beschäftigungen und loeb buchenhofen
betrieb und dann haben wir mal gemolken
und nicht das hätten das klappt jetzt
ist noch wachsen dem mond mond wäre
alles was hoch wächst ist gute
pflanzzeit
das hast du nicht gerne steine der halle
nervt aufgeweckt
ich find auch die man über das
flüchtlingsheim den innenraum chance
jetzt und da sie endlich seitens
wirklich ein bisschen schafften selbst
möglichkeiten zu es ist wichtig dass man
diese chancen auch immer an erwartungen
gebunden sind besteht immer auch die
möglichkeit dass etwas schiefgeht
niemand weiß zu diesem zeitpunkt ob
diese geschichte die so idyllisch
anmutet ein gutes ende nehmen wird
[Musik]
tesco hat keine ausbildung nach der
schule wurde er wie viele eritrea in den
militärdienst eingezogen 2012 kammer in
die schweiz
drei jahre lang lebte er im asylheim
an einem schnuppertag für das
integrationsprojekt hat markus den 31
jährigen kennengelernt und als dieser
die bewilligung bekam hat er ihn bei
sich eingestellt
ich direkt durch gemeint ist
erwerbsleben stehen
[Applaus]
erst jetzt sei es wichtig mit dem wissen
musik oder
weil es so gut arbeitet hat markus einen
ehrgeizigen plan mit ihm er will ihm
eine richtige ausbildung ermöglichen und
hat ihn vor einem jahr für die
zweijährige an lehre als landwirt
angemeldet die schule hat eine ausnahme
gemacht und ihn aufgenommen
[Musik]
markus und emmi halfen test zudem seine
frau aus eritrea nachzuholen
seit drei monaten ist nun auch mehrer
witt in der schweiz nur das junge paar
kennt sich kaum wie in eritrea üblich
wurden die beiden von ihren eltern
verheiratet
doch das ist schon acht jahre her
nein auf die gäste gleich
er hat jedes mal die vorher gegangen ich
nämlich hatte in der privat ein fachlich
14 musik dieses urteil das gar nicht
wenige sind ja mit ihm da einfach
nochmals offiziell
dass sie hat für das für die familie
zu
bin überzeugt dass sie darauf dass eine
app oder kennt diese situation und da
kann ja jetzt zwei autobesitzer dass sie
damit machen
april starb nach unten führen
wie merkt der familie noch nicht alles
war wie immer die theorie schwimmen
gehen hat ganz am anfang
nicht nur für tests vor und mehrwert ist
alles neu auch markus oder miranda allen
nicht auf welches abenteuer sie sich
eingelassen haben sie haben mehrere
offen in ihrer familie aufgenommen
die eigenen vier kinder sind erwachsen
nur die behinderte tochter susanne lebt
noch zu hause
markus ist 68
einer seiner söhne wird den hof
übernehmen bis es soweit ist möchte er
tesco als haupt arbeitskraft nachziehen
und selbst ein bisschen kürzer treten
tesco ist römisch katholisch wie die
hälfte der eritreischen flüchtlinge in
der schweiz früh verlor er seine mutter
wuchs mit seiner schwester und seinem
vater auf seine geschichte gleich der
vieler landsleute militärdienst flucht
nach libyen betrug durch schlepper
inhaftierung in libyschen gefängnissen
bis er von seiner schwester die es vor
ihm in die schweiz geschafft hatte
nachgeholt wurde
es sind zwei welten die auf diesem
bauernhof aufeinandertreffen
unterschiedlicher könnten tests vor und
markus nicht sein
und doch haben sie sich gefunden
[Musik]
die hand was wirklich vertrauen sammeln
ergehe sich gegenseitig emi nimmt mehrer
wird unter ihre fittiche um sie mit dem
leben in der schweiz ein bisschen
vertraut zu machen
[Musik]
ramsauers haben ein weiteres haus auf
ihrem grundstück
dort haben sie das junge paar in einer
drei zimmer wohnung untergebracht
amy hat für mehrere gleich daneben ein
fleckchen erde für einen eigenen garten
vorbereitet nicht so oft ja so deutlich
wie in trance
die rutsche zumbusch natürlich ganz
besonders für sie da die schützen an die
konturen an
man muss sehr offen zu ihrem stark ist
das holen wir werben
[Musik]
auch für tesco hat sich mit mehrarbeit
ankunft viel verändert
vorher verbrachte er seine ganze
freizeit mit freunden aus der römisch
katholischen kirchgemeinde in st
markus potthoff 32 hektar gemüse an
es ist frühling die kartoffeln müssen
ausgesät werden
[Musik]
wenn viel zu tun ist hilft markus
jüngster sohn mit und natürlich auch
tochter susanne und weil markus die
integration von flüchtlingen ein
anliegen ist beschäftigt er nun für die
kurzen einsätzen nicht mehr osteuropäer
sondern ausschließlich eritrea
die 31 jährige war um zusammen mit sechs
anderen flüchtlingen im asylheim der
nachbargemeinde mülheim
jetzt schauen wir mal mit der freundin
ganz los gegangen vor allem ich her
bewegen
de maizière heute ihr lieben leute
wollen immer mehr marken rama ist seit
vier jahren in der schweiz
sie hat immer noch den status als
vorläufig aufgenommene doch seit 2017
dürfen auch diese leute arbeiten
[Musik]
ja klar aber ich weiß dass ich heute so
schwierig das brötchen nennen
zum beispiel seien
wie viele karten mit 22 jahren sind
immer immer nur 1 2 1 1
wenn zwei zehntel schneller fahren weil
auch aber ihre sache gut macht hat
markus beschlossen sie fest anzustellen
obwohl er damit das risiko eingeht sie
bald wieder zu verlieren
diesmal herr schütte tun wenn sie
natürlich die herstellung hinzu aber
wenn sie auf die toilette tronic
[Musik]
markus stellt sich vor dass raser hier
bei testo und mehrer witt im oberen
stock wohnen könnte so würden sich die
beiden frauen gegenseitig unterstützen
[Musik]
sich einfach schöner sich die abc
captain america peheim heck das
vertrauen und alles ist einfach anders
verhalten ist direkt ab und baut auch
das hier wird sind wenn raffa arbeit
hätte und geld verdienen würde
viele sie dem staat nicht mehr zur last
markus ärgert sich dass man den
flüchtlingen in der schweiz wenig anreiz
zum arbeiten gebe
hier wo wir es schaffen diese batterie
setzen und zwar so schnell wie möglich
mit den geldern stört mich wenn es viel
wasser ohne dass man bis leicht arbeiten
haben wir die schau zur verfügung und
wenn wir mal nicht gäbe dann sieht man
selber schuld denn man muss einmal mehr
machen verschaffen wird sozialleistungen
jede woche mit also sieht man ein neues
bewusstsein
[Musik]
tesco bekommt von markus 3500 franken im
monat
abzüglich kost und logis das ist ein
voller lob woldt es vor noch in der
lehre ist
[Musik]
hier ist ja ich nicht ausgebildet werden
die spitze ist verfroren fehlen 1233
kerne fehlen
das wirkt sich auf den ertrag aus am
schluss der show lehrling oder also
auszubilden und dem moment mal die sache
bringen weil da wo sie die schule kenne
unseren lehrern der gottes so schnell
damit mir eigentlich jede zwischen 10
immer wieder sehen und dass sie sich an
absetzen oder was ist eigentlich die
aufgabe wenn ja wenn ich etwas schreiben
erklären
die herstellung gewaltig zu aber so
sicher mithalten kann will ich an sachen
oder bilderrätsel 100 prozent job karte
nicht weil ich einfach einen halben tag
geben
diese auch weniger kamen aber
wahrscheinlich kann intensivkurs lösungs
zu wenig gülle und mist ist dass bauern
nicht bei list list list ist schlau
da lässt auch liz ist auch christian ich
weiß nicht da müssen wir ein buch
schauen was liest ist ja ganz bewusst
aber es ist nicht das ist einfach das
milchtrinker diese pflanzen sind zu
bestimmen sie gehören zur prüfung also
pro schüler gibt es acht pflanzen du
bist zu bestimmen
einen tag pro woche besucht sv mit
bauern lehrlingen aus der region die
schule
die prüfungen sind schwierig für ihn
weil er oft gar nicht versteht was
gefragt ist
mehr als einmal die etwas 100 also tun
jungen sind auf die runde dass wir haben
mehr erwartet wieder wärmer verstaubt
schwierigkeit ist schon wieder sprach er
mit leiser aber verstehe schriftlich und
mündlich gibt sind glaube ich die größte
problem die individuelle betreuung die
hand bieten in ein glas mit zwölf jahren
heiraten jetzt jasmin abbrechen
dann gehen sie an ihren platz und da
kommt ärger
auf dem hof wächst und gedeiht
nur der plan mit rafa geht nicht auf
[Musik]
nachdem markus mit ihr einen
arbeitsvertrag abgeschlossen hatte
erfuhr er dass sie schwanger ist und das
ist sehr ungünstige zeit haben wir nicht
und eigentlich über alle alliance kruska
china zu dann haben wir zu erwerben also
in der polka walzer von denen mit dem
vater des kindes wir aber nichts zu tun
haben
ramsauers möchten helfen und sind bereit
sie arbeiten zu lassen solange sie kann
das muss jedoch mit der gemeinde
abgesprochen sein
denn rava ist nach wie vor nur vorläufig
aufgenommen
sozialvorsteherin charlott hunger bühler
kommt zum gespräch
die variante wäre sie hat jetzt ganz so
fremd so detail da gibt es wechsel oder
den hat einfach so wichtig sei wie sie
sich denn das auch vorstellen phase bis
zum wo sich die jetzt schaffe und noch
eine wieder eigentlich den auf mülheim
zugkräfte markus möchte dass raser auf
dem hof wohnen und nach der geburt
weiterarbeiten kann
aber die kosten für den
mutterschaftsurlaub findet er
die müsste schon die gemeinde übernehmen
wir sind den jährige stellt wenn sie
jetzt teurer ein paar wohne sie hat
einfach ihren betrag wo sie jeder hund
und erreicht respektive gemeint hätten
einen pauschalbetrag um ihr übergewicht
weil wir das alles finanzieren sich
auszahlt und sie ihre tat geld aber
woche und alles andere wird für honig
für mir die für krankenkasse spezial
also zahlungen für schuhe und so wird
und das auf buchen das geht relativ
schnell ebenerdige also drei mir nicht
viele fouls der fototage es wirklich
zieht der gemeinsam überlegt wie ich
aber das wirkliche handhabe wenn sich
zahlen geschrieben - pro tag das ist der
punkt und kanton bezahlt
gerade auf der kanton und der kanton
verteilt
das ist aber nicht meine bilder also da
war man braucht natürlich meint ja denke
dass uns wieder störfelder um einfach
ein muss ist
im augenblick bekommt rama 77 franken
pro woche wenn sie arbeit hätte könnte
sie ihr zimmer und die krankenkasse
selbst bezahlen nur für den
mutterschaftsurlaub müsste die gemeinde
aufkommen
die sozialvorsteherin verspricht zwar
sich um die angelegenheit zu kümmern
doch markus ist ernüchtert das sein
angebot auf so wenig begeisterung stößt
oder ist doch ihr hund einfach
verlockend einfach für die hre
nicht nur die gemeinde auch markus muss
rechnen
viele bauern in der schweiz geben auf er
arbeitet immer noch 14 stunden pro tag
und es wären noch mehr wenn er test von
nicht hätte zudem arbeitet er gerne mit
ihm
[Musik]
er versucht mit einer maschine priorität
da kann noch nicht das ersetzen
wir haben wir sind natürlich prüfen ob
die scheibe bei mir machen wir machen
prince fiel mir heute noch vor den der
lehrer sollte das mittelland und das wo
sie halten
denn freiheit oder was ist eigentlich
das wichtigste mehr macht hat einfach
was was in der regel ziehen
aber was sind die zahl nochmal sehen die
zweifache termine und nach lebensmitteln
[Applaus]
[Musik]
drei wochen später es ist juni
von rawa weit und breit keine spur
[Musik]
erreichen die vorkämpfe das land in
wahrheit finden sie von der gemeinde hat
markus ramseier nichts mehr gehört
[Musik]
nötig
eine ganze man sich wünscht alle höhere
grüne alle mülheimer meeres zimmer wo
sie den müll ein
da der fc eigentlich würde da war dieses
thema aufgeben würde der bund nichts
mehr bezahlen und das wolle die gemeinde
offenbar nicht ramsauer hat einen
verdacht sie hätte so ist das meint die
autorin die mit den zahlt der bund mehr
als steuerzahler
sie hätte doch seit der 70 ja da müssen
steuerzahler bringen
aber das jetzt macht dass ich so viel
wie befürchtet sieht die gemeinde keine
lösung für markus anliegen aus dem plan
für raser wird nichts
sie muss in mülheim bleiben emmi macht
er weiter mit ihrem integrationsprogramm
führt es fuß frau mira witt
[Musik]
löffel gabel einen der brunnen machen
auch bisschen an denken ja alles rein
was sie macht das gut und wenn sie es
gemacht hat dann alles bleibt möglich
dass sie so offen haben nicht alle sind
gleichermaßen begeistert dass sich
markus und mb für eritrea engagieren
ihre beiden söhne zum beispiel finden es
nicht so toll
[Musik]
[Applaus]
markus junior ist auch der einzige der
sich äußert er betreibt gleich neben dem
elterlichen hof einer hühnerfarm so
schlecht wie seiner mutter vermutet
denkt er über das integrationsprojekt
gar nicht unterstützt grundsätzlich das
gute liegt momentan bei der auswahl von
damals sehr sehr vorsichtig sie es
wieder passieren
nationalitäten das buch einfach nur mir
geduld und die zieht die ente betriebe
halten
[Musik]
er selbst arbeitet seit jahren mit
polnischen arbeitskräften die lichter
der landwirtschaft und frühere ich hatte
so sieht ihr worden sind wenn sie wieder
ein sind und ich wieder eine bucht ein
händler der junge kollege oder aber es
vermittelt
der vater sitzt betrieb wo ich habe mich
deine beine sind verfügbar sie als
mannschaft selbst im projekt mitmachen
würde er wohl eher nicht will ich nur
wenn ich merke ich mich wie eine pole
wenn afrikaner oder schafft wird die
nicht ich war zu bau und dass davon
etwas ist eine unglaublich schwierig da
muss ich einfach liegt rassismus problem
musiker vordermann sie das damit in
konflikten steht das gab die sind in der
politik ganz anders gestellt
ich kenne das nicht und die band das
nicht dass man einfach die alten und die
alten bringe zakopane markus findet es
mit dem polen einfacher er ahnt aber
schon warum sein vater es jetzt mit
eritrea probiert
es ist aber nicht nur die
herausforderung die markus motiviert er
fühlt sich auch verpflichtet
ich denke so viel über vor der
volkswirtschaft dass die outdoor für die
piste 34 führte ein technisch gar nicht
gern gehört aber ich meine die für die
integration geht es nicht besser
zudem macht es mit tesco auch mehr spaß
die kartoffelfelder müssen von unkraut
befreit werden ohne chemie
das braucht manpower
[Musik]
überall da wo ich neu ist du hier ist
doch was ist das ja mal melde augen es
kommen immer wieder
es kommen immer alle haben wir nicht
gefunden aber bei kräuter müssen sein
wir können sie muss weitermachen wir
haben einfach mehr machen als ich das
ist so toll meinte der vize meine wenn
ich auf die normale arbeit sieht appel
gelmini den bruch nicht voll gemacht
[Musik]
markus kann immer noch nicht reduzieren
im gegenteil auch am morgen ist er der
erste im stall ist und sie wird sich
nicht nur fertig sind faktor diese
freilich dienen der monika mord hätte
sich mehr auf lediglich
[Musik]
jeder macht sein ding markus von tesco
haben eine beziehung aufgebaut die nicht
vieler worte bedarf
[Musik]
kannst du noch gegeben hast du wieder da
bist ganz überwunden
er macht einfach aber gern auch uns
morgen heißt es bettina dungeons und den
tatsächlich auch rebell es liegeräder
mit der pflanze und tier wachsen ganz
gut aber davon gestern sich dann gern
machen
dazu halten die haie mit dem selber
baust fertig da musst du hast dann
kannst du schon geben die idylle scheint
perfekt
doch bei testo zuhause bahnen sich
veränderungen an
java ist zu besuch
sie ist im fünften monat schwanger und
sie ist offenbar nicht die einzige
zur großen überraschung aller erwartet
auch mehr witz ein kind
auch sie ist im fünften monat hat es
aber lange verheimlicht konkrete
vorstellungen wie das leben mit einem
kind wird hat sie nicht
[Musik]
auch testroom scheint es zu nehmen wie
es kommt
[Musik]
ok de mera witt muss kurz nach ihrer
ankunft schwanger geworden sein
markus und emmi lassen sich ihre
überraschung nicht anmerken
ernüchterung macht sich breit hat wenig
verständnis für passivität
irgendwann
weiß denn tesco wenigstens wie es mir
geht und was sie beschäftigt
offensichtlich ist jedoch dass die
gartenarbeit nicht mag
das ist vorbei
[Musik]
was würde sie denn lieber tun fragt sie
hat sie das hat körper sie hat schon
gelernt werden
es ist sommer
markus von tesco hätten in den randen
für ein schwätzchen rechts immer
hast du gesehen jetzt ist traut falls ja
nicht gute show machen
jetzt muss weg
es zeigt die nächste woche ja immer noch
sind sie zu zweit
doch das wird nicht mehr reichen wenn
die ernte beginnt
[Musik]
markus himmel malen muss im betrieb und
er hat wieder einen eritrea gefunden
wieder einen aus dem asylheim in mülheim
mit der sozialvorsteherin dort wolle er
aber lieber nichts mehr zu tun haben
ich mache mit dem kanton mit er zugang
eines kriteriums fangen wir wiederum
erste maja und sind diesen monat mit
dennis winter und den den bruchweg
teilnahme seit der sache mit rama ist
das verhältnis zur gemeinde müllheim
getrübt
[Musik]
markus hat einen termin beim
gemeindepräsidenten ein gespräch soll
klarheit schaffen
einfach von der bildung ja wir haben
schon recht kräftig
der gemeindepräsident will mit markus
alleine reden und keine stellung nehmen
eine stunde dauert das gespräch aber es
kommt nur schriftlich mit direct man
will einfach das schriftlich festhalten
ein antragsteller und ist sowohl auf
mündliche schwierig so unbürokratisch
wie markus sich das vorgestellt hat geht
es mit dieser gemeinde definitiv nicht
markus kämpft an vielen fronten auch
mehr witz passivität will er nicht
einfach hinnehmen
er hat sie überredet ihm die haare zu
schneiden
harmonie seminare coiffeuse die stange
auch immer zu einer frauen zum gefühl
monaten zeigen
andré kavai
aber folgen
doch
h
[Musik]
während markus versucht und versucht
gibt e mail langsam auf
auf mehrere zählt sie nicht mehr nach
einem halben jahr hat sie eher
integrationsprogramm auf eis gelegt
für mich sind das sehr einfach nicht
mehr selber die motivation sei gibt auch
im interesse zeigen die husky daran
jetzt machen was ihr wollt mittlere sind
30 einfach nicht und so habe ich jetzt
einfach mal ich bin mir mich nicht groß
um sie wie es bringt einfach nicht
[Musik]
auf die erntezeit hin darf markus nun
den eritrea aus dem asylheim in mülheim
zu 60 anstellen
der kanton hat grünes licht gegeben
ich glaube ja nicht so im visier kunde
den im betrieb selbst aber war dass
generika und der zweite ärger mit mensch
aufwendungen alltag wird marcus held
schon fast bayerisch an seinem
integrationsplan für die eritrea fest
auch wenn ihm die neue anstellung wieder
gehörig papierkram schild ausländer
bewilligung in holla was mitkriegt mit
der versicherungen und börsen
alles klappen oder
[Musik]
erneut hatte den eindruck dass die
gemeinde müllheim sein engagement für
die flüchtlinge nicht unterstützt
er wurde meinte das sind hier wurde
gesehen dass die dörfer und dass die
private der vcd in dem das gefühl die
macht viel mit tus sythen verleiht das
selber günther benz oder das wieder
rückzug machte aber vor dem niveau da
sind machte keinen rückzug freiwillig
der gotte keine noch keine ist das land
die wüste und miserabel dass dir die
hand
es ist herbst geworden vor zwei wochen
hat robbie angefangen der 35 jährige ist
seit 2005 10 in der schweiz ist aber
nicht mal vorläufig aufgenommen er hat
den schlechtesten status n und wartet
auf seinen asylentscheid
[Musik]
der rest finden
fast alle lehrer was uns da
kopfschmerzen
hier sind ja auf traktor aufgefahren wie
es gefahren wieder geht das
integrationsprogramm von vorne los
[Applaus]
wir machen was schön rechtsfragen nicht
nicht in mitte
markus ist froh hat er seine leute
zusammen
[Musik]
also
bei der kartoffelernte braucht es jede
hand
noriegas
aus
amy ist begeistert vom robbie ja denn
auch das so flink dem gerät nach dem
müsse
[Musik]
aber auch mit ihm gibt es schon wieder
probleme
das papier gebracht vor der entscheid
vorbild und als negativ und dann hat
sich das xte nie gesetzt führen und geht
jetzt also der rekurs schreiben erhalten
bis zum 20 20 oktober wirksam
und ich denke mit dem rekordsieg länger
durchhalten mal so lang
es nützt ein rekurs macht dass dafür in
der schönen aachen blieben aber so einen
fall noch einmal brauche die schweiz
heute vor
[Musik]
während der ernte hilft immer auch tests
fuß schwester ob war mit ihrem mann und
ihren kindern mit sie sind gerne hier
denn was auf dem feld liegen bleibt
dürfen sie behalten
[Musik]
alle übernachten bei testo megabit ist
mittlerweile im achten monat schwanger
und hält sich vor allem in der wohnung
auf tesco muss noch lernen muss ich
etwas schreibe
wir kennen ja beispiel wenn jetzt
kartoffelernte nicht aufdrücken nachher
nach schule und kosten
ende herbst die weide mussum gezeigt
werden
national praktisch lassen
der zwanzigste oktober ist bereits
vorbei und robbie ist immer noch hier
und jetzt kurz vor ihm stand sei die
situation noch einmal behandeln für mich
ist einfach so herr ansätze
robbie gefällt's
tesco hingegen fehlt er ist anderweitig
beschäftigt seine tochter salem ist zur
welt gekommen ist schon zwei wochen war
ein wochen später franken fest
glücklich bis hinauf ins haupthaus zu
emi herzfehler wird allerdings noch
nicht geschafft diese ist einmal mehr
enttäuscht und ein bisschen ratlos
mit dem zum hus co er bringt sie
wirklich nur dass hinter ihr geschlecht
gesteckt dass sie ihre das zeigt dass
das wichtig ist meine taschen gibt es
auch schon weiter
und sie ist sich konnte dose sie hatten
ihr top-pferd drehe ich das so sie
können am zwölften tag 1 mit seinen
neugeborenen bruder zum quasi ein
vitamin schule und nach hause bis 30
galt ich als vertraut sind es oft
schwierig die integration die mainzer so
harvey nash
und das findet auch markus ist nicht
zufrieden
durch die neue situation wird der kultur
unterschied auch bei tesco mit einem mal
ziemlich deutlich arbeitslosigkeit oder
weil er muss sich jetzt ziemlich stark
beschäftigen mit seiner familie jetzt
mit geburt ich noch mal zusammenreißen
und zehn wir halt wieder herbst
starteten innen und für mich natürlich
nicht unbedingt optimal nicht so optimal
ist auch test fuß tempo was die lehre
angeht
der neue weizen muss ausgesät werden
noch ein drittel dazu ein dritter jetzt
ist halb bis zu seinem lehrabschluss
bleibt nur noch ein knappes halbes jahr
muss doch auch machen nochmal grafik
macht manuela beherrsche wendt es zu
seiner priorität nicht bald anders setzt
drohe näher und damit auch markus
ehrgeiziges projekt zu scheitern
dass ich gut bin ich zufrieden
naja du auch bist du auch zufrieden
jetzt ja nein 1 kommunal nicht gut 1,8
1,9
der erste schnee da bleibt auch mal zeit
für ein bisschen schweizer tradition
[Musik]
wenn du migros ist auch 52 gramm
aber ich bin nicht kaiser meister nicht
den bauer nach drei vierteljahren ist
klar
vieles ist anders herausgekommen als
markus sich das vorgestellt hatte
maxi mobil auch ohne dass er eine
arbeitsstelle hätte und im tresor
schaffe aber mit mit den rabatten und
sie auf dem hof besser funktionäre die
sich untereinander ergänzen
mit dem nach hinten hätte es wohl auch
nie mehr auf den betrieb und trotzdem
markus ist überzeugt dass ein
kulturaustausch wie dieser nicht nur den
flüchtlingen sondern auch den bauern
etwas bringen würde
das ist so dass michaels vision höhnt
empfehlen
alles ruhig
dass ich nur ein glas ist perfekt
hiermit vor dass in ganzen schönen ja
das ist ganz schön qualität
es ist kurz vor weihnachten einen grünen
schneemann musste von der 2 durch und
familientag zwei monaten sind wir vor
[Musik]
stringer
vorher mache
so kann es immer noch
da
nimmst du das ja ich habe für dich
gemacht
ab was das heißt
[Musik]
das ist fleisch für ruhig
emi hat salem gehütet megabit war im
deutschkurs
[Musik]
ich möchte jetzt passiert dann können
nur einmal 90 war schon einmal zehn hat
sich ja dann habe ich hier viel gegeben
und dann hab ich was luxus ist schön
dass mal ein bisschen probieren mit
geben jetzt zu trinken
das war's
[Musik]
wenn sie genug milch hatte sie so rist
aber sie muss auch wenn jetzt drei
monate an
[Musik]
langsam so scheint es ist mir aber doch
in der schweiz und paris angekommen
[Musik]
heute antwortet frau deren kindern
freundlich mit hand und nur sehr
fachmännisch mit dem bild doch und
selber nicht so vom fleck das deutsche
regietheater leiste ganztag zu tun
das sind gallacher noch nicht ziehen
gott hat jesus wochen in gott und die
durch und reserven tag lang oder habe
ich die gold oder anfertigen konnte ich
glaube diese reihen hätte sein fach
denkt natürlich die dauer die haie aber
das sagen alle gärten die rechte für und
einfach zu nehmen praktisch jedes
wochenende ist es wo mit den leuten von
der kirchgemeinde unterwegs kein wunder
interessiert er sich für ms große
krippenfiguren irgendwann macht nicht
immer größer so groß ist
und da stehe einfach jedes jahr wieder
aber das ist so ist wie wir nach der
kirche erwartet sagen ich weiß nicht
weil ich ja die musst du zu denen machen
ja allein schafft wir sind das kleine
ich habe ja da macht die zu den schärfen
ja/nein macht den schafen ja sie
bezüglich das ist auch noch ansetzen
sollten klären
nicht ganz so aber zu hause ist eine
kleine frau mit lichtern
[Musik]
kurz vor neuer
große aufregung bei testo zuhause
töchterchens allem mit getauft
in eritrea ist das ein großes fest aus
der ganzen schweiz sind eritreische
landsleute angereist
[Musik]
alles glatt auch der eritreische pfarrer
aus st gallen ist extra für die
zeremonie nach mülheim gekommen rosalie
zum abendessen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
für markus ist diese taufe einer der
wenigen einblicke im test fuß welt
wir beantworten
ich recht lange gang und dass das kind
durch das also schnell hobby das ist so
ähnlich wie drückt mich sehr mitgenommen
können aber war sie schon egal es
verwandtschaft das heißt ihnen so
angehört haben wir gesehen was die
autonome die ganze stadt fahren einen
parkplatz
[Musik]
das fest haben vor allem opa und emmi
vorbereitet und papa und mama ihr seid
papa und mama von facebook das ist
echter mir das aber jetzt 14
aber das ist auch nicht
[Musik]
kaum ist die taufe vorbei taucht wieder
ein neues problem auf mehr abos
ausreisepapiere aus eritrea einreichen
solche hat sie aber nicht ramsauers
kommen aus dem papierkrieg nicht heraus
die hat schließlich der dritten ehe
mache das einfach so also sich um suizid
wo mir da wirklich wo ist er denn zum
innehalten und so machten eigentlich
danach lagen die büro einfacher 1000
dollar gesamt und wenn sie eigentlich im
prinzip fast unmöglich halte auch mit
der ausbildung von tesco hat markus alle
hände voll zu tun
die praktische abschlussprüfung ist in
gut drei monaten
wenn sich test nicht anstrengt rechts wo
nicht aber jetzt fiel haus bleiben und
wir haben viel in der schule
ich finde ich sie ein bisschen juli
ich befürchte aber jetzt nicht mehr
machen pastor ingo da mal harte prüfung
das ist ja ich verachte
er macht große sprünge zuversichtlich
bush seine pflichten negativ ist schon
allein im fachlichen teil oder der rasse
das authentische mehr bekundet im
praktischen teil herrscht hier sind
stunden angegeben nach wie viele stunden
muss etwas machen das 21 bei wievielen
stunden
alle 207 die 200 stunden gefahren bist
wieder musste ölwechsel machen und viel
verwechseln mit dem deutsch hapert es
immer noch
die freizeit aber freigesprochen
in österreich ist ganzheitlich weil es
wirklich knapp werden könnte hat die
schule einen nachhilfelehrer zur
verfügung gestellt tesco hat vor allem
probleme sich verständlich auszudrücken
was irgendwelche alles aber zum ende lag
ganz leer erklärt das problem er muss
einen vortrag vorbereiten also ich
möchte auch vor allem das dass du den
vortrag hältst und kannst du das auch
mehr erzählen wie das war als ok der
betrieb wird seit 21 jahren organisch
biologisch bewirtschaftet die auszahlung
lauf tal westen zeitweise von funke
krieg nicht wachsen
hast du so verstanden
ja du wirst am montag den vorteil auch
so halten also du hast da ein notizblock
machen aber man kann nicht immer so ne
na.de ja das ist damals ging es gut wenn
du machst das was du guckst auf das
planen und dann guckst du ja ja ja ich
habe immer mit dem kreis lippe herr
orange club show unter dem
erforderlichen schnitt um 4
emi hat erneut einen anlauf genommen
mehr aber ein bisschen schweizer kultur
zu vermitteln
[Musik]
auch und videos
aber wann gibst du sara am morgen
nachdem das ist ja nachher mindern
zwei wochen so darfst du noch heute
banane geben dann kann sie so um 12 uhr
eine gemüse geben und so um 45 uhr
kannst du banane
nein du kannst jetzt zwei wochen rollen
dann aber das hier ja das dass die
deutschschweizer dich mittwoch mit 4 1
die würde dieser verstehen und stehe zu
allen möglichkeiten nicht nur mit reden
kommen wir den ball laufen lassen und so
und aber bis jetzt hat auch leander
stimmt das finde ich wichtig wie sieht
das auch so legt
[Musik]
es ist märz tesco ist durch ein
integrationsprojekt des bauernverbandes
auf den hof von markus gekommen
nun will vize direktor urs schneider
sehen wie es läuft
[Musik]
dieses problem sei tue
wenn man das einfach nur zeige ja wohl
schneller theorie macher mit den
härtefällen und dennoch erschaffen
einfach den laufpass aber ich glaube
schon sehr wichtiges hat die richtige
person erschöpft war willig ist somit
bis lernen und auch die küche
bereitschaft zu schaffen und zu trinken
das feature august sein oder spielt
sicher eine rolle aber man einfach folge
oder also möglichkeit meine arbeit ist
natürlich auch ein spezial sei notwendig
wenn der schau wieder schafft und auch
mit ja mit überzeugung und wendigkeit
danach schotter denn funktioniert dann
nicht geliefert und dass ich wieder auch
nicht handicap im moment können
oder einen riss der tempel obrigkeit hat
sie beim abbruch beliefert wird die
gegenseitigen erwartungen verdeutlichen
können erfüllt werden oder es wird sich
sicher es wird welchem maße das machen
oder hätte eigentlich denkt dass denn
das findet sicher stehen und endlich den
teil von denen arbeitskräfte bisher rosa
musste wo sind vielleicht könnt ersetzt
werden
dass wir dort zu sehen und wie sie
hoffentlich eigentlich oder erwartet ist
das denn jetzt das war mal auf
nationaler ebene als pilotprojekt
abgewickelt
denn der kanton st denn er fortsetzung
finden denn sie immer natürlich wieder
mit gemeinden und biete migration sind
gefordert sind denn da war wirklich sehr
aktiv die verhältnisse schaffen oder ich
höre einfach der gemeinde das super
lecker dass hier das dir verdienen
wir haben können aber so eine aufgabe
aber jetzt jeder meint innenhof des wo
alles gute
nochmals danke vielmals gute zeit
[Musik]
abstoß dekoration
je mehr emi wieder mit mir zu tun hat
desto mehr realisiert sie was die junge
frau stört sie steht morgen hole ich
mehr avid beruft zu
weißt du ja in schaffhausen geht's luca
vitali ist das mit uns nacht miteinander
im internet sei für ihn ist das
selbstverständlich will damals auch
kaufen und sich familie und die quote
von emmi und markus versuchen zu
vermitteln
doch bei tests für und mehrer bett hängt
der haussegen ziemlich schief
[Musik]
es gibt wieder mehr zu tun auf dem hof
die renten müssen gesäubert werden
[Musik]
mehr witz problem mit den ausreise
papieren ist immer noch nicht gelöst
tesco hat eine neue aufforderung
bekommen die papiere einzureichen
das ist dass du musst etwas machen du
musst etwas machen sonst muss vielleicht
dann frau wieder nach eritrea dass ich
nicht gut
und da musste es allem auch gehen das
ist nicht so einfach weil ich muss mir
die botschaft geht nicht anders und mehr
arbeiten muss mit kommen wir ja ja sie
muss gehen
kein problem markus kann ausnahmsweise
nicht helfen
dieser angelegenheit müsstet es vor
regeln aber der zeitpunkt ist denkbar
ungünstig
die prüfungen stehen an und die ehekrise
mit mehr avid eskaliert
am tag vor test fuß abschlussprüfung
verschwendet märz spurlos
[Musik]
aber wenn ich also weniger ck für sie
und hoffe dass ich dir einfach nehmen um
xi r rating sagte die siko laufe mit dem
kinderwagen um siebeneinhalb jahre lange
lumix den hat er trauert meravis wester
lebt in zug mit viel überredungskunst
gelingt es markus sie zurückzuholen
doch was die gründe für ihr verschwinden
waren weiß markus nicht mehr avid ist
zwar wieder da und scheint doch abwesend
ehrmann tesco ist überfordert
[Musik]
gefangen zwischen den ansprüchen der
neuen heimat und den gepflogenheiten
eritrea
[Musik]
ich finde ich kein lehrbuch ja ist das
feld wo ich weiß wie viel er mit ihrem
land etwas für zuständig also für
verlosungs krieg als klar fällt
man fragt sich warum tests vom ära wird
überhaupt die schweiz geholt hat
wieder versucht markus zu vermitteln
das gut um mehrwert bei laune zu halten
hat er ihr sogar einen hofladen
eingerichtet aber die eheleute gehen
sich aus dem weg wann immer es geht
[Musik]
ein paar wochen später auf diesen tag
hat markus langer und unermüdlich
hingearbeitet
trotz aller privaten turbulenzen hat es
wo die abschlussprüfung geschafft was
wegen meist ja wenn die klippen ist wie
frau
[Musik]
das nicht erreiche mit muss das ziel und
auch einmal danke dafür dass da so dass
das ich habe auch oliver h ich hätte
mich überzeugt ja es kommt auch wieder
als retter und fielen auf ein anderer
weg oder monat zu monat direkt vor ihm
sieht das vom die mutter ihren typisch
rundtour ist ein großer tag für dich da
dort sitzen wir noch etwas machen
da warten warten warten bis nach vorne
der anlass ist festlich und traditionell
schweizerisch
80 bauern lehrlinge schließen dieses
jahr in der ostschweiz die dreijährige
lehre ab drei haben wie tests zusammen
die zweijährige attestlehre gemacht
tesco genießt es teil davon zu sein
juni
[Applaus]
[Musik]
jetzt setzt die absolventinnen und
absolventen ganz herzlich begrüßen
möchte ich die vier absolventen jetzt
twitter
insgesamt sind vier kandidaten treten
daher alle hier bestanden
der betrieb von markus ramseier hatten
durch bildung erfolgreich abgeschlossen
mit 67 erfolgreiche kandidaten jetzt
nach vorne richten
ebenfalls auf bühne
ich habe
trotz einer zweieinhalb in der
theoretischen prüfung im praktischen
teil hat es wo alles wettgemacht
[Musik]
er habe ich probiert und bin überzeugt
sie vorrang haben in der woche zwei
jahre hinzieht und tiefgang papier ich
so viel mehr führen
würde er es wieder machen ich höre sie
immer machen
timo verlegt wo mich und ich führen muss
erst alles andere probieren und sich
anderen das buch geduld und vor allem
viel aufbauarbeit mit tanner
das ist doch alles menschliche emi und
markus laden zum essen ein
[Musik]
auch emmi ist erleichtert
deshalb passen einfach
während jetzt einfach das urteil aber
die familie und dienst bis 2
heute ist kein tag zum grübeln
alle freuen sich über des fonds erfolgt
[Musik]
vier monate später test arbeitet nach
wie vor auf dem hof aber seine private
situation hat sich grundlegend verändert
ein paar wochen nach seiner
erfolgreichen abschlussprüfung ist
mitgegangen und hat töchterchen zahle
mitgenommen niemand weiß was genau
geschehen ist
nun müssen sich die behörden mit dem
gescheiterten familiennachzug befassen
du bist nicht so wie markus es gibt auch
nicht viel zu sagen
markus hat alles versucht und konnte es
doch nicht richten und es steht zwischen
zwei kulturen und versteht die welt
nicht mehr
ob er seine tochter wiedersehen darf ist
völlig offen wieder hilft markus wo er
kann
und wieder ist es froh darum allen
kulturellen differenzen zum trotz markus
ist und bleibt wie ein vater für ihn